in diesem video zeige ich euch einen
super genial in einfachen trick mit dem
ihr eure tomatenernte verdoppeln oder
sogar verdreifachen könnte kein witzen
und alles was ihr dafür braucht ist eine
elektrische zahnbürste beziehungsweise
eigentlich nicht mal das denn
das ganze funktioniert auch ganz gut von
hand falls sie mich noch nicht kennst
ich bin marie ich spreche hier ganz viel
über das thema gemüsegarten und auch
ganz viel über das tomaten anbauen wenn
du also selber tomatenanbau ist dann
lass gerne ein abo da und drückt auch
die glocke damit du informiert wirst so
weit ein neues video erscheint diesen
tipp hier mit der zahnbürste den habe
ich wirklich noch nirgendwo geteilt das
ist etwas was ich letztes jahr selber
neu gelernt habe und was so gut bei mir
funktioniert hat dass ich das wirklich
sehr gerne an euch weitergeben möchte
also herzlich willkommen in meinem
tomaten dschungel sprechen wir erst mal
über tomaten die sind nämlich ein
bisschen anders als manche andere gemüse
viele andere gemüse wie zb die zucchini
haben ja männliche und weibliche blüten
und die männlichen bestäuben die
weiblichen bei tomaten ist das ein
bisschen anders da sind beide
geschlechtsteile in einer blüte das
heißt die tomate die kann sich selber
beschreiben aber damit es dazu auch
kommt muss die blüte bewegt werden und
das im besten fall von insekten das ist
aber gar nicht immer gegeben zb hier im
gewächshaus nicht weil hier kaum
insekten reinkommen wir haben hier zwar
drei bienenstöcke gleich um die ecke
stehen aber die bienen kommen nicht ins
gewächshaus im professionellen anbau wo
ich ja auch viel gearbeitet habe
haben wir dann immer so kleine hummel
kisten gekauft und die ins gewächshaus
rhein gegeben das ist natürlich eine
super option aber ich möchte es bei uns
nicht machen weil es eben auch super
einfach ohne solche hungen geht und
helfe da ein bisschen mit der zahnbürste
nach aber im freiland kann das genauso
ein problem sein zb einem regnerischen
tag bei trübem wetter wenn die bienen
nicht richtig fliegen oder allein schon
wenn du viel attraktivere blüten in
deinem garten hass tomaten sind jetzt
nicht unbedingt so die favoriten der
insekten oder der bühne
dann kann es sein dass die biener
vorbeifliegen und seine tomaten nicht
bestäubt werden und deswegen helfen wir
da am besten nach denn das macht einen
riesenunterschied wenn du dir mal so
fruchtansätze anschaust dann siehst du
das ganz oft abgebrochene zweige an
frucht ansätzen sind wo eigentlich
früchte sein sollten und das sind blüten
die nicht besteuert wurden hier sieht
man zb ganz gut dass hier die blüten
nicht bestäubt wurden die sind einfach
abgefallen und dadurch haben sich jetzt
hier keine früchte entwickelt in den
anderen blüten aber schon da sieht man
an diesen ansätzen ist dir was entgangen
da hätte eine frucht dranhängen können
tut aber nicht weil das mit der
bestellung aus irgendeinem grund nicht
geklappt hat und deswegen ist das ganz
sinnvoll hinzugehen sogar einen pflanzen
und ein bisschen nachzuhelfen ich habe
die beobachtung gemacht dass wenn man
nichts macht wenn du dann die tomaten
hier einfach so stehen lässt das dann
ungefähr 30 prozent der blüten bestäubt
werden und die restlichen fallen ab
dadurch dass ich aber nachhilfe und beim
bestäuben helfe habe ich jetzt aber
super fruchtansätze das heißt weil sie
jede blüte die sich an meinen pflanzen
bildet entwickelt später auch eine
frucht und dadurch kannst du der
ausrechnen wenn man vorher 30 prozent
der blüten früchte verwandeln kann und
jetzt 100% kannst du deine erste easy
verdreifachen deshalb sich richtig
reißerischen ich hoffe ich werde dafür
jetzt nicht von euch zunichte gemacht
weil es tatsächlich so so gut
funktioniert also probiert das wirklich
mal aus und ich zeige euch jetzt wie das
funktioniert wenn die insekten an die
blüte fliegen wird nämlich der pollen
durch die vibrationen vom männlichen
teil der blüte in den weiblichen teil
transportiert und das wollen wir nach
machen und deswegen machen wir jetzt
unser zahnbürste an und die vibriert
ganz schön dann halten wir an die an die
blüte und dadurch wird der pollen vom
männlichen in den weiblichen teil
transportiert schubst easy peasy schon
ist unsere blüten befruchtet und
entwickelt eine sehr leckere hübsche
riesengroße tomate schauen wir uns mal
ein paar blüten an hier haben wir eine
geöffnete blüte die bereit für den
geschlechtsakt ist hier haben wir eine
blüte die schon geschlossen ist das
heißt sie ist erfolgreich befruchtet da
wird sich dann eine tomate dran bilden
und hier ist eine knospe die ist noch
nicht soweit dann ist es noch ein
bisschen warten bis die richtig
aufgegangen ist aber wenn die richtig
aufgegangen sind dann kannst du da
hingehen und die zahnbürste einfach mal
20 sekunden lagen an den fruchtansatz
halten sodass der pollen richtig schön
in der blüte dorthin transportiert wird
wir ihn haben wollen du kannst das aber
auch wunderbar von hand machen
viele haben ja keine elektrische
zahnbürste da kannst du einfach so mit
dem finger an die blüte dran gehen und
da vibrations- bewegungen machen was
finde ich noch viel schneller geht ist
wenn man die ganze pflanze nimmt und
einfach ein bisschen schüttelt ich habe
das am anfang nicht gemacht weil ich
dachte das hilft nicht so gut und man
muss das mit jedem blütenstand einzel
machen aber in den letzten wochen habe
ich das nur noch so gemacht weil es ja
doch bei 40 50 tomatenpflanzen die wir
anbauen relativ aufwändig ist jede
einzelne blüte da zu behandeln und die
pflanzen haben trotzdem super
fruchtansätze also das scheint auch
super gut zu funktionieren und geht viel
schneller als wenn man jede einzelne
blüte durch geht also einfach die
tomaten und ein bisschen schütteln
natürlich vorsichtig wir wollen die
nicht verletzten die brechen die auch
schnell ab also seid lieb zu euren
pflanzen aber das funktioniert auch sehr
sehr gut ich habe übrigens alle meine
tomaten tipps gebündelt in einer
anleitung zusammengefasst für euch die
ihr euch gerne kostenlos herunterladen
könnt dann ist so ein ganzer leitfaden
also von der wortwahl über die aussaat
bis hin zur ernte steht er alles drin
was ihr wissen müsst mit allem was ich
über tomaten weiß und wie man sieht
funktioniert das ganze sehr sehr gut
denn wir können uns nicht mehr lange hin
bisschen vor tomaten nicht mehr retten
können
ich freue mich schon wahnsinnig wir
haben schon die ersten geerntet die
ananas tomaten waren dieses jahr
übrigens die allerersten tomaten die wir
ernten konnten obwohl ja so riesig sind
also die waren wirklich so groß wie der
kopf weinend meines sohnes
das war eine ganze mahlzeit für uns drei
also der absolute hammer richtig tolle
sorte und die waren obwohl sie so riesig
sind wirklich die allerersten tomaten
die wir dieses jahr essen können und das
tolle an diesen zahnbürsten trick ist
dass du deine erntejahr enorm
vervielfachen kannst wenn du dass du
machst das heißt du kannst ja ungefähr
doppelt so viele oder dreimal so viele
tomaten ernten und das heißt wenn du
einen kleinen garten hast brauchst du
auch viel weniger tomatenpflanzen in
deinem
garten weil du ja viel mehr von deinen
pflanzen ernten kannst ich würde mich
total dafür interessieren wie viele
tomaten ihr so an bord wir bauen ja auf
jeden fall über 40 tomatenpflanzen an
irgendwann wird es dann auch zu viel wir
verarbeiten die ja auch kochen die ja
auch ein dazu kommt übrigens auch noch
ein neues video zum tomaten sauce
einkochen freue ich mich schon richtig
drauf weil das ist ein superschönes
leckeres rezept aber ja verratet mir mal
wie viele tomatenpflanzen ihr anbaut und
ob ihr euch damit selbst versorgt oder
ob das mehr so ein kleiner garten snack
ist ab und zu mal ob ihr das auch selber
ein kocht oder nicht das finde ich sehr
interessant zu hören und auch ja ich
finde es ist immer so unterschiedlich
wie viele tomaten leute anbau und manche
kommen mit drei pflanzen hin und sagen
sie kaufen trotzdem überhaupt keine
tomaten zu und manche sagen ich habe 50
aber 150 oder ich genug also schreibt
mir gerne ich freue mich immer von euch
zu können aber nochmal zum trick mit der
zahnbürste zurück das funktioniert
übrigens vormittags am allerbesten so
zwischen neun und elf habe ich gelesen
sind die pollen am bestäubung freudig
ssten ich weiß nicht was genau das
problem noch mal war ich glaube vorher
sind sie noch zu feucht und verklebt und
hinter ältesten der blüte ein bisschen
zu trocken
deswegen ist es am allerbesten wenn du
das vormittags machst ich mache das so
ungefähr sagen wir mal ein bis zweimal
in der woche und je alle meine tomaten
durch und er macht das mit denen am
besten am wochenende wenn man unter der
woche vormittags arbeitet da mache ich
das dann sei nicht meine tomaten sowieso
aus geiz und blättere übrigens ich
verlinke euch da oben mal eine playlist
wo ich die videos die jetzt gerade
wichtig sind ganz an den anfang packe
das ist das düngen und das ausreizen die
sind gerade beide sehr sehr wichtig dass
man daran denkt wenn man tomaten
angebaut so dass ihr da schauen könnt
welche ja welche tomaten angelegenheiten
ist gerade zu erledigen gibt damit die
pflanzen schön gesund bleiben und
kräftig wachsen und ganz viel ertrag
abwerfen wenn ihr schon ganz viele
tomatenernte dann völlig ich euch da
drüben mein absolut liebstes
fermentieren zum fermentieren von cherry
tomaten superlecker sommer snack müsst
ihr wirklich ausprobieren da unten packe
ich euch nochmal die playoffs mit den
tomaten tipps hin so dass ihr da weiter
schauen könnt wenn ihr wissen wollt was
da gerade wichtig ist bei euren tomaten
ansonsten sehen wir ins nächste woche
wieder ich freue mich total auf euch bis
dahin tschüss